no the queen consulted she wanted to
know why he was off school
a little green well i think it's a
reasonable excuse and something you're
going to remember forever yeah okay well
thanks for speaking to us the crowd's
dispersing now that magical moment now
over here in cardiff as the king leaves
the welsh capital
we're taking you to surrey uh per bright
to be exact the new prince and princess
of wales visiting an army training
center to meet with troops from the
commonwealth who have been deployed
to the uk to take part in the state
funeral of her majesty the queen on
monday
a state funeral involving thousands of
troops from right around the
commonwealth this is the prince and
princess of wales arriving a few moments
ago they'll be meeting soldiers from
canada australia and new zealand who
have been
at that army training center rehearsing
their roles
in monday's ceremony let's just listen
in
the prince and princess are going to
meet with senior representatives of the
defence staff and service people from
each nation as well there in surrey to
thank them for the part that they will
be playing
on monday and the part they have played
so far in marking the death of her
majesty
the queen and we did see the new
princess of wales at perbright army
training center not so long ago actually
and she took part in a training day
herself to
learn more about the armed forces i
think it was to mark armed forces day
and she was there and we saw her
literally being hands on in some of the
training exercises that troops undertake
it's important for the royal family uh
to reach out to the military because of
course the queen and now the king head
of the armed forces the armed forces yes
and um
i think it's there that i saw kate a few
years ago go presenting shamrock to the
irish guards uh yeah the relationship
between the royal family and the
military is um
is pretty fundamental and and most of
the um
the queen's children have some
involvement in the armed forces and
we'll see that tonight weren't we with
the um
the vigil with the wearing of the
uniforms and so on so the um
it's always been paramount right way
through from the queen
um
serving with the ats at the end of world
war ii and uh prince philip serving
throughout the war
um
and amongst the royals have a number of
different military titles and just some
news that we've had into us here on sky
news this afternoon there was a lot of
talk about
the vigil that's going to take place
this evening involving the queen's
children and of course the vigil taking
place tomorrow evening involving her
grandchildren but we understand uh from
the palace that prince andrew has been
given dispensation to wear military
uniform at this evening's vigil
but there's no confirmation as to
whether he will or not there has been a
lot of talk about that and prince harry
as well because both um of them no
longer having those military titles but
perhaps wanting to wear their uniforms
as they have served well absolutely and
i think the um the the main thing is
that the royal family won't want a
talking point because once the funeral
is over on monday
there's going to be analysis for the
next week two weeks or whatever talking
points people saying well it was all
right but did you see that bit where
you know that lying in state and they
didn't wear a uniform something like
that it's important to um
to show solidarity and not to give a
kind of
and also perhaps not to give harry the
excuse of you know one day com saying i
wanted to wear a next uniform and i
wasn't allowed or something we don't
want that kind of uh
thing that takes away from the the
solemnity of the occasion well it sounds
like they will be given permission to at
their own personal discretion to make
that decision as to what they want to
wear ian lloyd at role biology thank you
for a moment
sarah jane thank you
these are live pictures from cardiff of
the king and queen consort they left the
castle here a few moments ago they're
now pulling up at the helicopter for
that journey back to london and i have
to say the crowds here
absolutely delighted they had queued
from the early hours of this morning to
get into the castle only 2 000 were
allowed in
and they were hoping that the king would
walk along the line and say hello to as
many of them as possible and he and his
wife did just that and people now are
slowly going home
with many memories many recollections uh
and many thoughts of what they've just
experienced and what is a momentous day
the very first trip to wales for
the new king king charles iii joining me
now is professor elizabeth treasure who
is vice chancellor of aberystwyth
university uh lovely to see you
professor first of all can i just remark
on your name i mean it's quite the name
to have right now it's a it's a
fantastic name yes thank you very much
i'm very proud of it elizabeth treasurer
wonderful well we're watching pictures
professor of the king uh leaving cardiff
what do you make of the reception he's
received hasn't it been a warm reception
on this strange day of such mixed
emotions
fitting farewell to his mother and a
super service this morning in the
cathedral and then this fantastic crowd
really pleased to see him this afternoon
and why not because he he loves wales
and you're the vice chancellor as we've
said of aberystwyth university somewhere
that holds a special place in the king's
heart yeah he came to aberystwyth before
the investiture just over 50 years ago
to learn welsh and we've seen him it's
using his welsh today which is fantastic
he studied for 10 weeks the language the
culture the history under the late
professor teddy millward
many people around the world have seen
it on on the crown and he lived in the
hall of residence alongside other
students
and had as far as we can tell a good
time there learning welsh and he spoke
as you say at welsh today when he gave
his response to that motion of
condolence
i don't speak welsh but it seemed to me
like he did a pretty good job how do you
rate it he did a pretty good job i'm a
learner it's not an easy language to
speak in public it's quite scary and i
thought he did a pretty good job today
so well done him for learning lessons of
the last 50 years and i think that time
at aberystwyth in 1969 is that's correct
will um uh have put him in good stead
because it shows that he made a real
effort to
learn about this wonderful country he
made an effort to learn the language and
he didn't necessarily have to do that
but he did it because he knew that this
was a role he wanted to take seriously
yeah i think it's really important i
think people forget how important the
language is to the people of wales how
many people use it as their first
language how many is it um it's about
twenty percent um and and where i live
in carrier digion it's it's around half
the people it is their first language my
office is first language welsh um and i
think what was important there was that
he lived with welsh speakers who wanted
to live their life through the medium of
welsh um and and and joined in so we
have a student who's an alumnus who's
put on facebook how strange to share the
same cleaner mrs brandon uh as the then
prince of wales so he really engaged
because he wasn't um in a separate
turret at the castle he wasn't in the
grounds he was mucking in with the other
students he had a room i think the there
was also a room for security but he had
his room which people still point out as
the prince's room
and you met the uh king the former
prince of wales of course not so long
ago i did he came to aberystwyth he's
come back to aberystwyth several times
but he came in november to mark the
opening of the first veterinary school
in wales in aberystwyth and what struck
me very much was how much time he spent
talking to every one of the students he
was really interested engaged he also
talked to the staff about the
environment about about about the
problems we face in rural life and he
showed his interest in the university
and rural life in the united kingdom
not everyone in this country is a fan of
the monarchy uh the prince of wales has
a has a long and checked
history of course that that title where
do you think we go now in this big
moment of transition what will the
relationship between the monarchy and
the country be
that's a really hard question
it's a tough one and today i think when
we're looking past such a fantastic
uh life of service from her majesty the
queen and now forwards to king charles
iii
we live in a democracy no doubt it will
pan out as the people want but i think
it's going to be um a debate that will
continue to roll but for the moment
we're celebrating the new king and
remembering her late majesty
and the queen was held in huge affection
here she was she was and again um i i've
met her in cardiff um again engaging
with students and the young and the
future and really inspiring students in
those meetings uh by being interested in
their work um and and i i have immense
respect for her in that role and also in
her role as a as a woman leader
i've spoken to lots of young people over
the last week and
uh touching on what you said there we
know that the prince of wales as he was
was fairly opinionated he had strong
views on lots of different things but
one of those things was the environment
wasn't it and although in his new role
he won't be able to give those opinions
in public in the same way i think a lot
of young people a lot of students at
aberystwyth will
appreciate that and it's something that
they will see as a good thing in the new
one i think so i think what the this
generation are so concerned about is is
climate change is the environment and i
think when we see what's happening in
pakistan just at the moment you can
absolutely see how absolutely critical
it is that we do address the
environmental issues and the
universities in wales aberystwyth but
the others as well are all addressing
some of those really important questions
we do a lot of work on future food
security something that's absolutely
critical at the moment
well as we watch pictures of the king
leaving cardiff uh flying off back to
london in the helicopter we can reflect
really on what a remarkable day it's
been it's been a whistle-stop tour
really of cardiff you've seen the main
landmarks hasn't he he's been to
beautiful landau cathedral he's been to
that very modern building down by the
waterside the senate
where the parliament sits and then here
at the castle two thousand years of
history here
professor
and of course this was a day that was
planned meticulously absolutely
every detail
every detail covered from the first
moment of arriving in the car park
watching him arriving in his helicopter
taking off just now what a fantastic job
everybody involved in that has done i
think we should just be incredibly
grateful for
a fantastic day people have worked so
hard all the people of cardiff and
beyond it is a great city isn't it it's
really been shown its very best light
today and i was going to ask you as well
about the crowds that turned out because
there had been some talk that perhaps
people would be a little bit ambivalent
about the visit today but i've been
really struck by the huge numbers that
have turned out i i i only saw crowded
streets i saw
very little other than celebration and
memory today and on this beautiful day
as you say
around the castle in this historic site
what a fantastic day for wales and how
good of him to come at what must be
personally a very very difficult time
and do you think you'll see the king in
aberystwyth anytime soon have you
extended an invitation yet maybe a bit
too early too early inappropriate at the
moment but we do hope to maintain that
relationship with us as one of our
former students um he's been very
generous to us with his time over the
years and i hope that he will come again
and if not we will no doubt welcome the
new principal it certainly sounds like
uh it's going from strength to strength
to university
yeah lovely to see you professor
elizabeth treasurer wonderful name at
this very sad time vice chancellor at
wrestling university uh thank you great
to see you much appreciated
well we are watching pictures from a
little bit earlier of the king greeting
the crowds here at cardiff castle as i
was saying they had waited many hours to
get into the grounds here and meet the
king and their wishes were granted and
it's really struck me today just how
grateful the king seems that so many
people have turned out to to meet him
and offer their condolences he's been
receiving gifts flowers
and the like from them um
it's not been uh uh
sorrowful in fact i would say it's been
almost the opposite it's been a day of
joy for for these people i'm grateful
that they've managed to see the king on
his first day
in wales as monarch but of course now
things do turn
for charles he's taken that helicopter
ride back to london and what today has
been a day of meeting and greeting with
not only members of the public but of
course
the great and the good of cardiff and
wales people from many faiths people
from charities politicians from the
senate as well
well now things
change somewhat the mood the tone will
become much more somber and to tell us
why is our royal correspondent laura
bundock that helicopter making its way
back to the capital laura
where the king alongside his siblings
his two brothers and sister will at half
past seven this evening hold another
vigil around the coffin of the queen
inside westminster hall we saw the same
vigil didn't we on monday evening at st
jars cathedral in edinburgh and after an
incredibly busy week
and i think just the events of today
reflect how
frantic it has been for the king
touring the nations
meeting and greeting the spiritual the
political and the people as well
and certainly the people who are here in
cardiff they've been on their feet since
six o'clock this morning they didn't
want to miss a trick of this visit but
tonight as i think the king heads back
to london
thoughts will obviously turn to the
state funeral on monday and what will be
another very poignant moment i think
inside westminster hall as we see the
vigil and of course over the weekend
heads of state arriving
tens and tens of them into london
with a huge
reception for them on sunday night at
the palace hosted by the king and queen
console
okay laura thank you very much indeed
our royal correspondent laura bundock
there reflecting on events of this
evening as we reflect on events of today
watching king charles as he
slowly works his way along that line uh
less than half an hour ago meeting
children who've taken off uh taking the
day off school for this momentous
occasion
meeting people from all ages all walks
of life or wanting to be here to pay
their respects we must remember that
behind the smiles behind the chairs
behind the flag waving
behind the costumes that some people are
wearing is a man
very much in mourning a man grieving the
loss of his mother and i'm sure as he
continues his journey in that helicopter
his thoughts will turn to what are bound
to be an incredibly difficult few days
as we
watch
those rehearsals we see those plans that
have been in place for so long being put
into action culminating in monday's
state funeral of queen elizabeth ii
well the king now heading back to london
his majesty will host a reception for
faith leaders in the bow rim of
buckingham palace a little later on uh
and then this evening his majesty will
depart buckingham palace to head there
to westminster hall he and his siblings
the duke of york the princess royal and
the earl of wessex are to hold a vigil
in westminster hall much like we saw
them carry out
in
edinburgh these are live pictures inside
westminster hall
and
you can see a member of the police there
paying their respects as the public far
past
thousands
man
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
a senior member of the royal family
when diana died because that wasn't um
she wasn't a member of the royal family
there wasn't um
the royal family didn't come out and and
mark the occasion publicly and there was
trouble but i remember when princess
margaret died the queen carried out
engagements and i was at one and we were
told and the public was told not to
mention the fact that princess margaret
had died because the queen wanted i
think to protect herself and and not to
break down or be involved so this is
very different isn't it i mean people
are the royal family are closely
involved there was hugging of uh with
the counters of wessex in manchester and
with kate yesterday leading a small
child over the barriers to put flowers
down it's a very touchy feely sort of
approach and
helping as we said earlier to share the
grief a joint thing we're helping them i
think they're helping us over this uh
this time of of still this shock for
many people i think
well we can see the prince and princess
of wales they're talking to soldiers
from canada australia and new zealand
all have been
dispatched to perbrite to rehearse their
roles in the ceremony
they're taking their time to have those
conversations with them uh unfortunately
we can't hear any of what is being said
uh the prince and princess are going on
to meet senior representatives of the
defence staff and service people from
each nation to thank them all for the
part that they will play in marking the
death of her majesty the queen
and those rehearsals
continue while the conversations go on
between the royals
and the armed personnel
ian this weekend
heads of state global world leaders huge
names will be
heading to london for the state funeral
on monday we understand the prime
minister liz trusts will be
holding informal meetings to to greet
them and welcome them to the uk as part
of that as will the king himself
in terms of
the funeral on monday
is interesting isn't it we're hearing
about great world leaders like president
biden and the emperor of japan having to
get on buses to go to the funeral
president being told he can't have his
normal security detail with him
you know this really does show the
hierarchy
in global world affairs the monarch
seemingly right at the top when it comes
to this yeah i remember being outside
westminster abbey for the queen mother's
funeral and it's quite funny you see a
coach i think it was a local coach from
windsor pull up and then all these kings
and queens get off you know there's um
it's quite a
leveling experience for them i'm sure
because they're all used to convoys of
cars and so on but uh yeah the president
of the united states is uh
probably slumming it for the first time
in his life i would think as as leader
but um
it's it's it's a historical moment and a
vast gathering of heads of state and
i wouldn't be surprised if there isn't
some sort of group photograph taken
because it's such a marked occasion back
in 1910 here at buckingham palace when
the
queen's great-grandfather edward vii
died
there was a great gathering of europe's
kings and queens on the eve almost of
world war one later many of those
monarchies disappeared but because it
was such a
vast gathering of royalty there was a
photograph famous photograph taken of
george v
with the guests including kaiser wilhelm
the second his cousin
to mark that occasion so it could be
something similar this time
apologies for the movement there in the
pictures uh a cameraman obviously being
asked to move there is those
military exercises those rehearsals for
monday state funeral continue the prince
and princess of wales they're talking to
representatives from commonwealth
nations canada australia and new zealand
who
have come to surrey to carry out those
rehearsals ahead of monday and because
ian this is
a global event millions of eyes will be
on this state funeral
and it's important to get it right this
is a real show of not just the uk but
the commonwealth well a great deal of
planning has gone into it and
you're right they won't want anything to
go wrong they won't want anybody snubbed
nobody to go home feeling that they
didn't get them um
a moment with the king or whatever it is
and you have to remember of course now
that the king is king of australia and
new zealand and canada and the
commonwealth is a vital part of his role
as head of the commonwealth back in
2015 the queen in malta asked
the leaders of the commonwealth if they
would support i suppose charles is
um role as head of the head of the
commonwealth which is not automatically
a royal one it could have gone to any of
the leaders of the the nations but um
uh they did indeed vote him in as as as
the next head of the commonwealth so
it's uh he's not just a king of this
country but
several others
yeah we saw the prime minister of new
zealand jacinda ardern inside
westminster hall earlier paying her
respects
to the queen and jacinda ardern saying
that she will be meeting the king over
the course of the weekend uh although
the the timings are yet to be worked out
um
just in terms of what we're seeing here
the queen obviously head of the armed
forces and so many
members of the royal family have um
titles associated
with the armed forces um and there is
some talk about reallocation of titles
and things like that and a lot of people
looking at the new princess of wales as
to whether she may assume one at some
point
yes i mean i think it's it's natural now
with the passing of the queen we've got
a considerable number of military
appointments and roles that um
she was involved with that will uh need
to be passed on i remember that when the
queen mother and princess margaret died
prince andrew said they had all the
patronages that the two
ladies were involved with on a card
table at sandriam
and they all went round as a family and
sort of picked various ones that they
felt appropriate for them sort of
so they're a considerable number i mean
the queen was involved with something
like 800 charities and patronages and
these will
uh some of these will be default d um to
give them to the members of the royal
family that particularly as you say kate
now she's um
princess of wales in a more significant
role the prince of princess of wales
coming a little closer to the camera
you'll have to just excuse the the
movement there obviously uh the press
assembled there uh to try and catch a
word with the prince and princess of
wales and to to follow their visit are
being moved
around to accommodate them let's listen
in and see if we can can hear something
of what's being said
beautiful
[Music]
is
um
um
um
[Music]
any space left in the brain or like
languages
and have you been a part of these
jubilee celebrations
about
basically
um
um
is
um
come back
i guess
the princeton princess of wales in
surrey at the army training center in
herb wright to meet troops from the
commonwealth who have been deployed to
the uk to take part in the state funeral
of her majesty the queen they're taking
their time
to talk to those from canada new zealand
and australia
and ian lloyd former role photographer
and role biographer in the studio with
me watching these scenes and
in you commenting that new zealand and
australia
the royal family uh tours there have
been very successful there has been some
talk in recent days
of the new prince and princess of wales
uh being sent there soon on a raw tour
to to forge that relationship
absolutely yes i mean the queen went to
australia 16 times in new zealand 10
times um in the early days it was a vast
undertaking she had to go by c and she
spent five or six months
down there in 1953-54
these days it's obviously a lot easier
to get there but um camilla in
particular i think finds the the
long-haul flights quite uh difficult um
and um
i think given that the age of the the
wales is and the fact that
certainly they're both very very popular
down there
by chance in the queue for the lying in
state with with a group of australians
who said
they absolutely adore their kate in
particular and they were looking forward
to to seeing her
and um
like with william and harry when they
were little it's possible that they'll
take the children with them and so on
so it's uh it's important time i think
to um
to keep that relationship going with
those countries
we've seen
prime minister of new zealand jacinda
asked dern in london today she was
inside westminster hall paying her
respects
to the late queen and
in recent days she said i do not believe
that new zealand will become a republic
in my lifetime um
such is the the changing at the head of
the royal family the queen becomes the
king and
in modern times there are more questions
being asked about
the purpose of the commonwealth
uh in this modern era and those are all
questions that this new royal family are
going to have to
try and answer
over the coming years well i think as
we've seen um in the last few days and
the week since the queen died that
even the role of
how we we deal with the passing of a
monarch is changing so uh the nature of
the relationship with the commonwealth
will change and be re-evaluated i would
imagine and it's very much down to
william and kate and that generation i
think to adapt the traditional role of
the monarchy and to be seen to be uh
relating to to australians and new
zealanders uh in the way that they're
relating to people here you know to
adapt that role and uh take on
causes that would be beneficial for
those countries and that they can help
with i think
uh prince william uh his relationship
with the armed forces he completed seven
and a half years of full-time military
service and
since then he's been very much promoting
the important role and the welfare of
those who are serving or who have served
their country in the armed forces as a
key focus particularly when it comes to
his charitable activities and perhaps
you could explain to us the the medals
that the prince of wales is wearing
there yeah i mean they're not just um
the medals aren't always automatically
given for service in uh for fighting
they're also given for ceremonial
reasons and
the medals that he will where he's
wearing there would under undoubtedly
have been given to him by the queen
um to um commemorate the golden jubilee
of the diamond jubilee in 2012 and the
platinum jubilee earlier this year and
harry has a set and all the
members of the royal family the working
members of the royal family would have
been given them as well so it's um is to
commemorate the key events in the
queen's reign
we were talking about the importance
of the armed forces to the royal family
and
there will be vigils held inside
westminster hall by senior royals
tonight at around 7 30 the king will be
joined by his siblings
and we understand from the palace that
prince andrew has been given
discretionary permission to special
dispensation to to wear his
um
military uniform should he so wish it's
going to be a personal choice of prince
andrew and then on saturday evening we
have the queen's grandchildren um
all eight of them
taking part in their own vigil again
prince harry we understand
is being given dispensation to wear his
military uniform
symbolic yes but also of personal
importance to prince andrew and prince
harry who both served
yeah absolutely and they're in a
position where they're um
both separated from the royal family so
this is bringing them back in the fold
so to speak
i think prince andrew definitely um
would want that there were there was
rumors that he um he spent time at
balmoral earlier this summer with the
queen trying to
talk about his future role and there are
suggestions that his two daughters
beatrice eugenie
tried to bend the ear of the new king to
try and say look you know what can we do
about daddy he needs a role um
because he's
effectively uh almost a former member of
the royal family because he's no longer
working and we saw it in the summer with
the troop in the color ceremony which he
would normally take part in
and he was um effectively banned from
that so it's it's a very tricky
situation uh the new king has got to
sort out um
what to do about his brother and also uh
what to do about harry although harry
has forged a new um
life in america and prince charles sorry
king charles i beg upon in his speech
said wished them well didn't he in
in their future in america
if you're just joining us here on sky
news we're looking at live pictures um
from an army training base per bright in
surrey the new prince and princess of
wales are there
meeting
soldiers from canada
australia and new zealand soldiers from
across the commonwealth who have been
deployed to the uk
to take part in monday's state funeral
they are there in surrey
to rehearse to rehearse their parts in
monday state funeral a funeral that will
involve
thousands
of military
personnel and
ian in terms of a spectacle
this will be quite something it's going
to be beamed around the world millions
of people watching
and as i said thousands of armed
personnel involved the pomp and the
ceremony everything that is typically
british will be on display and the plans
have been decades in the making
and the execution we expect will be
quite something to watch yeah absolutely
i mean it's i've been surprised at the
involvement of the commonwealth troops
although obviously as we talked about
the queen was head of state of australia
new zealand and canada and so on um but
the funerals that we've experienced
certainly in my lifetime with the queen
mother and diana didn't have that
element and we have to go back really to
the coronation of the queen in 1953 when
um
commonwealth troops were brought over to
this country and uh it was interesting
that's how prince philip
developed the use of that royal
helicopter which the prime minister
winston churchill
tried to ban him from using but philip
found it a very efficient way of getting
around the country to visit these
various um
groups from across the world that had
come over but it's almost a sort of
spectacle in the way that the coronation
is but obviously
not a celebration but a commemoration
just looking at the prince of wales
they're talking to representatives from
the armed forces
in canada and
what we've been commenting on today ian
is the
amount of time that senior royals are
giving those that they are speaking to
over the last few days given it is a
difficult and busy time they are in no
rush events in wales have run over today
because the new king wanted to take his
time for everyone that turned out to see
him whether they be
dignitaries or members of the public and
you're very much getting a sense of this
here in surrey normally
with you know a visit such as this you
have somebody at their elbow
gently nudging them along to keep them
to time there's no sense of this here
prince william for example has been
speaking to this group of soldiers for
the last five minutes there is no sense
of urgency no i don't i think they don't
want it to appear that they're
ticking boxes they're just doing this to
because they have to or they should do
what's coming across in the last few
days is that they're doing this thing
of involving people whether it's members
of the public or the armed forces
of the visiting heads of state they're
doing it because they feel
very much that it's appropriate that
they want to do it
and as we were saying earlier i think
both sides are helping each other i
think they're probably getting a lot
back from um we can't hear what these
people are saying at the moment but i
bet there's there's something supportive
things about the queen and about um
the king and about williams involvement
so it's um
it's yes it's it's a it's a very nice
thing and when you look back at the the
beginning of the queen's reign the lake
queens reign
there's a great element of formality if
you look at photographs of her meeting
people whether it's at film premieres
or the armed forces there's great
distance the queen will hold her arm out
and they will hold their arm out there's
quite a few feet between them but it's
been interesting this kind of
touchy-feely uh
monarchy that we've seen in the last few
days it's it's a again a modern
departure yeah we can expect to see
more of that over the weekend
until monday monday of course
when
ceremony
and tradition
will be played out in full
and
you were telling me a tale earlier on
about the queen and in terms of the
queen didn't travel to funerals for
heads of state or members of the royal
family around the world
she preferred private reflection and he
told a lovely story about her
actually going out
in disguise almost in the crowd to pay
her respects at a funeral yeah that was
the um funeral of field marshall
montgomery montgomery of el alamein the
wartime
army leader who um died i think in 1969
and the funeral was at saint george's
like the queens
um the queen wasn't at the funeral and
she wasn't represented well she probably
was represented but she didn't attend
the funeral so what she did she was
living at windsor at the time as she put
on a head scarf and went into the town
of windsor and stood stood with the
public behind a barrier
just watching
montgomery's body pass by
and as you said with with overseas i
mean she only went to one as far as i
know which was king borderland of
belgium in 1993.
um
she never really also attended ones for
family or friends because uh well sorry
i beg upon family yes but not
friends
necessarily because i think she thought
her presence was a disruption
so quite often she went to memorial
services for friends but not um
the funeral but certainly in terms of a
head of state she only went to one as
far as i know
well if you're just joining us the
prince and princess of wales are
visiting an army training base in surrey
this afternoon
troops from across the commonwealth
canada new zealand and australia have
been based there
to carry out rehearsals for monday's
state funeral and
william and kate taking their time
to speak to people there
as we alluded to no rush we haven't got
any sound on the pictures at the moment
we did catch snippets earlier on and
there was a reference made to somebody
speaking five languages
and of course a message
a mention of rugby
of course prince william a big rugby fan
i'm sure he has
a few stories to swap with
the soldiers from new zealand and
australia about that let's see if we can
listen then
[Music]
yes
[Music]
is
ever looked back
um
um
is
directions
[Music]
uh you're watching those live pictures
from surrey of the princess of wales uh
talking to uh some of the
female personnel uh from the
commonwealth troops that have been
brought to the uk to play their part in
monday's state funeral joining us now in
the studio kate williams royal historian
kate
so much has happened over the last few
days there's still so much more to
happen before the state funeral on
monday
it's important to take a moment isn't it
and just try and take it all in the
enormity historically of what we're
witnessing unfold in real time yes the
enormity as you say i mean very few of
us have ever seen a state funeral we had
winston churchill's in 1965 and some
people remember that but of course that
wasn't the royal state funeral that was
an exception the main royal state
funerals we've seen were for edward vii
and george v and george vi the queen's
father grandfather great grandfather so
i think very few people remember the
funeral for george vi in 1952 many
people remember the queen's coronation
but not so much that and this is such a
huge moment it is a moment by which we
give thanks for the queen's 70-year
reign but also really the enormity of
this historical moment for us 1952 2022
how much britain how much the world has
changed in 70 years and as you've been
talking about that there will be change
to come there is going to be change to
the commonwealth probably change to the
different park constituents the
different different parts of different
countries that have the queen as head of
state and we are not just a moment of
great sort of great historical change
and i think the future will look back on
this movement 100 200 years time and and
and really see it as a defining moment
for britain
well we're looking at
part of the immediate future of the
royal family the prince and princess of
wales their new titles they're getting
used to it they've had them for a few
days now and the king
kate you'll have been following his
progress today he was in wales in
cardiff
and he got a huge reception there had
been some talk about not knowing whether
the crowds would be as big in wales to
turn out to see the new king as they had
been in say edinburgh or london talk us
through
the history of the royal family and its
association with wales how how it's
poised at the moment yes the prince was
saying the king excuse me the king was
saying what a privilege it had been to
be prince of wales for so long he spoke
bilingually he spoke in welsh speaking
well speaking welsh first and of course
spent some time in wales learning welsh
as well um and
and it is a language that he was keen to
learn and
it's it's always been had a place in his
heart and he talked about he talked
about the
listing when he visited the senate and
the welsh parliament was having heard
your heartfelt words i know we all share
the deepest commitment to the wealth of
the people of this land and talked about
how committed his mother was to wales as
well and wells has always been such a
special place to the royal family but in
a different way to scotland there is not
an equivalent of balmoral there in the
same way and
certainly um the crowds have been great
and they i think there is that there was
a there was a concern that they might
not be as overwhelming as they have been
but certainly there have been a lot of
people who came out to see the new king
but charles you know has has a has a
road ahead in terms of the unity of the
united kingdom and the unity of the
united kingdom at scotland wales and
northern ireland
and of course
prince william
and his wife assume the title of prince
and princess of wales and of course they
have an association with wales
having lived in anglesey before prince
william was elevated to a much more
public status within the royal family
they had that private time there so
there's there's that connection as well
kate but i just want to look ahead to
the state funeral on monday we've been
getting more details about it and we've
had some details about the route
actually um after the queen
leaves westminster abbey we'll bring you
some details of that a little bit later
but what can we expect from a state
funeral can you give us some things to
look out for because as you said most of
us will have never seen a state funeral
before this will be the first experience
of it we
the majority of us are going to look at
it on our tv screens and be able to see
every moment and every movement and
really soak it all up so what should we
be looking out for yes it's going to be
a huge moment and just as you were
saying there on wales the the love for
the royal family and it's interesting
one interesting point is that the queen
was never princess of wales we don't
have a name in the british royal family
for an heir to the throne who was female
so she was never princess of wales
whereas of course now william is prince
of wales in anglesey uh my father's home
my father's birthplace beautiful part of
the world and um the state funeral we
many of us have never seen this we
remember ceremonial funerals for the
queen mother for princess diana and for
the duke of edinburgh which was
restricted due to covid the key
difference in the state funeral
ceremonial funeral is that the gun
carriage bearing the coffin is pulled
forward
by not horses but by servicemen and so
and and that's what's going to happen
we're going to see it being pulled
forward by royal navy servicemen that is
the key difference but there are many
great differences and many smaller
differences because the monarch makes
their own choice as we were just talking
about the role of the commonwealth
troops is very significant and this is
the first state funeral we have had in
western mr abbey since the 18th century
they've generally been at st george's
chapel windsor and that really reflects
the scale of the event so many world
leaders are already here we've just come
up jacinta arden was already here the
the prime minister of australia was
already here and joe biden we think
probably is coming over or is already
over we don't know and there are there
are so many world leaders world royals
and it's so sick poignant isn't it to me
that the queen began her reign
she was crowned at westminster abbey she
of course was married at westminster
abbey just a few years before she was
crowned at whistler's rabbi in 1953 and
now she will end her reign in western mr
abbey as well
and you're watching pictures live from
surrey the prince and princess of wales
they're greeting troops from the
commonwealth who are based at their army
training camp for the next few days as
part of rehearsals for the state funeral
on monday
and ian lloyd world biographer is in the
studio with myself and kate williams the
historian and
kate there mentions the gun carriage
apologies if you could hear some noise
above us that is a rather
large aircraft going over the studio
it's actually making the studio shake
i haven't got eyes on yet it feels and
sounds like a chinook
but i'm no expert i'm just waiting for
it to come into view
um
but ian kate there referenced the uh
oh let's just pause because the hacker
is being carried out by troops from new
zealand
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
foreign
foreign
so
oh that was members of the new zealand
army performing the hack of the
ceremonial dance in maori in her
majesty's memory for the princess
and prince of wales here at buckingham
palace the royal standard has been
raised
king charles
is due to arrive back in buckingham
palace the loud sound you heard here in
the studio may well have been his
helicopter
landing close by the prince and princess
of wales there in surrey uh speaking to
troops from the commonwealth canada new
zealand and australia thanking them uh
for their part in marking the passing
of the late queen and talking to them
about the rehearsals that have been
ongoing for days now and will continue
right up until monday and that state
funeral and ian just before we went to
the hacker there
we were talking about something kate
mentioned that's a key part of a state
funeral and that is the gun carriage
that will carry the queen and it is
pulled uh not by horses but by members
of the armed forces and there's a story
behind that how it came to be part of
tradition yeah i believe it was at queen
victoria's funeral in 1901 and they were
at windsor station waiting to
take the the queen's body on a gun
carriage up the hill castle hill to
um
some george's chapel when the horse is
sort of bolted and the traces the
leather connection to the um
gun carriage were broken and i think
there was a moment of panic and then
somebody very sensibly suggested that
the cadets from eaton who were lining
the route could possibly pull the gun
carriage which they did and
it became one of those moments in in a
royal ceremony that uh we'd take us by
surprise a new departure that uh
and it was so popular and caught the
imagine imagination of the public that
ever since when the monarch
dies the naval ratings
pull the um
the cortex you know so
and kate we've been talking about the
pomp the ceremony the tradition that we
are witnessing and something that has
emerged from the monarch's death is the
idea of vigil now it was called the
prince's vigil i understand and we saw
the princess royal take part in the
the vigil in edinburgh and there will be
another one held by her children tonight
in westminster hall and then tomorrow
night her grandchildren
will
stand vigil with
her majesty
and
it's interesting not just because female
members of the royal family are taking
part but members of the royal family who
do not have royal titles as well it's a
real
changing of tradition as we go yes it
really reminds us that the queen
monarchy the huge monarchy outside
buckingham palace here and um but really
at the heart of it was one person and
she was a mother a grandmother and a
great grandmother and it really is very
meaningful very significant it really
reflects anne's role in the family and
the queen's real trust for anna and
played this key role
she accompanied the queen from balmoral
to edinburgh she accompanied her on the
plane from edinburgh to raf bryce norton
and then now she's walking behind the
coffin and also in the vision of the
princes and it really reflects i think
it looks like charles arriving there is
it coming in that's right that's uh it
looks like king charles and the queen
consort
at buckingham palace were just waiting
for the car to come through the gates
there
something they've landed and they're off
to clarence house
[Music]
charles and commit i think chuck charles
and the queen consult were heading from
the booking palace to house so the
crowds are delighted they've been
waiting here all day they've caught
their glimpse of the king and he's
returning to clarendon's house because i
believe he i think was his right isn't
it he hasn't quite moved into buckingham
palace yet
monarchs are supposed to move into
buckingham palace but of course it it's
a transition they have a home there they
have to try to took the queen when when
her father became king quite a quite a
time to move into quite a few months
before they moved from their town house
in piccadilly to buckingham palace so so
it's a process so they're heading back
to clarence house now they have to move
into buckingham palace because the queen
hadn't lived there for a couple of years
during covet she officially said well
palace is her official residence
um but she made the decision to stay at
windsor
um so
does king charles have to they pick up
the officials there they usually live
there but it is monarchy hq isn't it
it's not a home it's an office it's sort
of a giant office there are 775 rooms it
is the working heart of monarchy so many
people rather prefer there are other
residences that they perhaps can be a
bit more intimate with with family and
friends uh certainly but i think charles
will be using it so frequently for uh
for for state occasions for the
occasions that he must be at he probably
will eventually move in at least have
rooms there but uh certainly they're
very fond of clarence house but it's
luckily it's just around the corner
plans i think 1949 wasn't it when the
queen moved in there princess elizabeth
they'd only just been married a couple
of years and it had been redecorated
with their choice hadn't it philip and
the queen um as as princess elizabeth
and duke of edinburgh they decorated it
and they wanted to stay there and um it
was winston churchill doing all the diy
i think the duke loved doing all the diy
and the renovations i think they they
chose the wallpaper and the curtains and
everything and then it was winston
churchill that put his foot down and
said
to the palace they will go you know
there's a story about
phillips
private secretary mike parker saying the
four of them went in a car and there
wasn't a dry eye in the car as they went
to buckingham palace they hated the idea
and it's such a shame when you think
about it it's interesting isn't it we've
done so many royal events here and often
after we've seen the queen do a royal
event and be on the balcony we're all
still here just packing up and then the
queen's car is heading off to windsor so
certainly it's not many people's
favorite favorite royal residence as
beautiful and majestic as it is but
charles will spend a lot of time there
he has to
and with prince and princess of wales
are
seemingly wrapping up their visit in
sorry let's just listen in and see if we
can catch a few words of what's being
said
[Music]
um
[Music]
okay
that's crazy
okay
well that is the prince and princess of
wales uh leaving the army training
center at purbright in surrey having
greeted troops from the commonwealth uh
canada new zealand and australia taking
a little break from their rehearsals
well i say taking a break um there were
rehearsals ongoing uh as that audience
with the princeton princess of wales was
taking place um i've got kate williams
the royal historian
and ian lloyd the royal biographer in
the studio with me and i've just had a
statement in from the earl of wessex
that i will read and we can react to
that this is the first public statement
we've had from the earl of wessex prince
edward he said as a family we have grown
up learning to share our parents
especially our beloved mama with the
nation her realms and the commonwealth
while it has been lovely to have spent
time saying our own farewell privately
at balmoral it is now time to allow
others to be able to say their farewell
we have been overwhelmed by the tide of
emotion that has engulfed us and the
sheer number of people who have gone out
of their way to express their own love
admiration and respect to such a very
special and unique person who was always
there for us
and now we are there for her united in
grief
thank you for your support you have no
idea how much it means
the queen's passing has left an
unimaginable void in all our lives
sophie and i have taken huge pleasure in
seeing our james and louise enjoying the
places and activities that their
grandparents love so much
given that my mama let us spend so much
time with her i think she also rather
enjoyed watching those passions blossom
those times together those happy
memories have now become massively
precious to each and every one of us
may god bless her majesty and may her
memory be long cherished even as the
baton she has carried for these past 70
years now passes to the next generation
and to my brother charles
long live the king
that's a statement from the earl of
wessex and for far
in just your reaction to that we were
talking earlier about
the new monarchy and we're seeing the
earl of wessex here
uh in manchester yesterday he was there
um with the countess of wessex sophie
about them being much more open
emotionally it's a new generation we're
all a new generation from when the queen
started her reign and that was a very
emotional statement absolutely it's
really heartfelt and there's been such a
change certainly in my lifetime i mean
at the beginning of the queen's reign
for a starter don't think they issued
statements about uh about the loss of a
member of the royal family but uh the
queen's early speeches and and
declarations were incredibly formal even
you know when she was crowned 1953 and
they issued one from
buckingham palace it was very very
uptight very formal i mean this is
incredible and and also even the way
they refer to themselves you know sophie
and uh
the children um james and louise james
and louise there's no illusion even the
queen in the last year there's been a
change hasn't the last couple of years
when she referred to philip in rather
than my late husband my beloved
duke of edinburgh or something it was it
really is a change thought that um
to make the royal family less sort of
elitist but you know part of the greater
family of the country i think i think i
think the passing of diana had a really
cataclysmic effect on how the royal
family saw themselves because they'd
always felt that they should be
restrained and leave their tears to
others and that really at the moment of
diana's death that seemed like aloofness
that seemed like stiffness and so the
queen really when she came on and gave
that a dress
just before diana's funeral and talked
as a grandmother and praised diana's
gifts and really gave this very
emotional speech within within the
parameters of mourning a very emotional
speech and i think that really you know
lots of people talk about diana's death
sort of ending the stiff upper lip for
britain i've seen lots of articles on
that but i think also for the royal
family really it showed them that um if
you don't sort of acknowledge the grief
and really people people are
awesome
not happy but people are asked of very
accepting to hear about your own grief i
think maybe wars before it felt it was
selfish to talk about their own grief
but now they feel that they can do and
people will find that not selfish and
not at all instead really
joining together as as we do when we
lose someone we gain sort of heart from
being together and being sort of